in the previous video we saw that if we
have a right angle triangle like this
with sides a B and C then the Pythagoras
theorem says that C squared will equal a
squared plus B squared let's move on to
a new page to understand why the process
to understand the Pythagoras theorem is
pretty similar to the one for a plus B
the whole squared we draw a line of any
length and mark a point on it this point
can be marked anywhere on the line we
name the parts a and B this length will
be a plus B next we complete the square
with a plus B as its side this is a
square in which each length is a plus B
now we try to make the same division on
each segment we mark points here here
and here the points should be marked
such that this length is B this length
is a this is B this is a and these two
lengths are also equal to B and a we can
see that we have four points one on each
side this time we join the adjacent
points if you draw this on a piece of
paper you will notice that the figure
formed inside is a square let the
lengths of the sides be C centimeters
look at the different parts that are
formed the outer square is made up of
five parts this square of side C
centimeters in between and for right
angle triangles with height a and base B
let's zoom out a bit and try to find the
area of the outer square the area of the
square can be calculated in two ways the
first way is side x side it can be
written as a plus B multiplied by a plus
B which equals a plus B the whole square
and the area of the outer square also
equals the sum of the areas of these
five parts the area of this square is C
squared observe that each of these
triangles will have the same area as the
height and base is the same area of each
triangle is half a B to include the area
of four triangles we just multiply this
with for that total area would be 4
multiplied by half a B 2 times 2 is 4
and we get the area of the outer square
as C squared plus 2 a B both these are
the area of the outer Square equating
these two we can write C squared plus 2
a B equals a plus B the whole squared
and using the identity for a plus B the
whole squared we write this as C squared
plus 2 a B equals a squared plus 2 a B
plus B squared and cancelling out to a B
from both the sides we get C squared
equal to a squared plus B squared this
is the Pythagoras theorem